[Applause]
i was um embarrassed for for will
i was horrified for chris rock to
actually hit somebody was it was like
shocking frankly nothing nothing nada
sero condones violence in this form some
people just snap he snapped the ladies
of the view weigh in on the oscar slap
heard around the world
wow it all went down on sunday night at
the 2022 academy awards when comedian
chris rock made this joke about jada
pinkett smith jada i love you g.i jane 2
can't wait to see it all right
yeah jada who has been vocal about her
struggle with alopecia and autoimmune
disorder which causes bald spots and
hair loss didn't like it and neither did
her husband will smith who got up out of
his seat and hit chris across the face
oh wow
wow
will smith just smacked out of me
lit my
wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my
wife's name out
at first you thought oh my god it's a
skit oh my god just wait a minute
there's no punch line wait whoa it's a
punch not a punch line
ouch
man
crazy
yeah it was just so shocking
i was wild
i was definitely wild that was why the
whole thing was crazy well the show went
on and the 53 year old actor addressed
the incident when he accepted the award
for best actor for his portrayal as
venus and serena williams dad richard
williams in king richard
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
love will make you do crazy things
hokkien academy invites me back thank
you
and on monday whoopi goldberg joy behar
anna navarro and sunny hostin chimed in
with their two cents
i was thinking comedians are in danger
everywhere yeah
that you know they want us to be edgy
they want us to go out there and say
things that other people are just
thinking
they want us to take a risk
and uh and then they get mad and while
joy pointed out that these are tough
times for comedians anna noted that
hitting someone is an actual crime
hitting somebody is a crime right it is
the crime assault
on national tv it was men behaving
badly
on sunday the los angeles police
department confirmed in a statement to
e.t that they are aware of the incident
adding that chris declined to press
charges
wow
will smith just smack out of me as for
sonny she thinks will owes chris an
apology will apologize to the academy
and he apologized to uh his colleagues
and the other nominees but he didn't
apologize to chris rock no and i thought
chris was the one that deserved an
apology i think that will was immature i
think he was childish and i think he was
violent and all that echoes what john
leguizamo told et following the big show
i would like to more of a straight
apology
to chris i thought will's performance
was amazing and i'm sorry that he
tarnished it with this behavior nobody
likes to be made fun of but you got to
have a sense of humor about yourself
can't take yourself that seriously
whoopi who has both hosted the show and
won an oscar had a little more sympathy
for will i just think you know it's a
lot of stuff
probably built up he had one of those
moments where it's just like
gd it just stop not everybody acts the
way we would like them to under pressure
what i do want to say is i think it's
remarkable and wonderful that chris rock
did not take it
to that other place it could have gone
sometimes you get to a point and you act
you behave badly i myself
have behaved badly
on occasion on monday the academy of
motion picture arts and sciences
launched a formal review into the
onstage incident releasing a statement
that said they will explore further
action and consequences in accordance
with their bylaws standards of conduct
and california law but whoopi doesn't
think will should have his oscar taken
from him we're not going to take that
oscar from him well
i'm sure but i don't think that that's
what they'll do particularly because
chris said listen i'm not i'm not
pressing that
[Music]
you